i got a theory for why the patriots may
be welcoming the idea that they're going
to trade up to get justin fields because
what else is spinning while this rumor
mill is churning on justin fields
oh jimmy garoppolo may be traded before
or during the draft oh the patriots may
be the team
that gets jimmy garoppolo well you know
kyle
we're we're just we're just going to go
with one of these rookies well you get
this guy wants 25 million dollars and
you want a
first round pick or a second round pick
you want back the pick you gave
us four years ago right you're in route
ready to unload the guy because he can't
stay healthy and you think he's worth a
second round pick give me a freaking
break yeah so it could be
just part of the effort to squeeze jimmy
g to take
far less than 25 million and the 49ers
to take
less than that second round pick that
they may be stuck on
if they're going to trade jimmy g now
yeah
it's a good thought i mean you're right
you could use that as a negotiating ploy
because too just like we talked about
yesterday and you've been saying this
from the start with jimmy g
too like we know bill belichick
he's not gonna pay three cents if
something's worth two and a half cents
he's just not gonna do it he's gonna be
like well can i cut this penny in half
and give you that because it's only
worth two and a half i mean that's the
way he is
there's there's no way he's gonna trade
for jimmy garoppolo to your point at 25
million dollars a year
so i would think that 49ers and shanahan
and lynch are going to have to work some
magic like carolina did with teddy
bridgewater
and lower that number pay a a a chunk of
that contract
to where now the patriots or if anybody
else that's interested in jimmy
garoppolo
will be more accepting and i think also
you'll get more back right in return if
you're the 49ers if you could just take
away
some of the money as far as that asset
and the draft pick so
what you're saying is uh not a bad
thought
definitely not uh i understand that my
thing mike
the other thing i was gonna say would
like
if if new england's thinking about
moving to pick
four i think there would be other
motives there
that to me like the thing i would go to
was like wait why would they be going to
four what would they be doing
and that's where i would go to i think
there's a better bet if they trade to
four
that they're trading the four because
they want to get in front of the bengals
and take jamar
chase or penne sewell it's one of those
two that to me would be more of the new
england type of thing to do
than i think the justin fields pick but
we'll see tonight that's for sure
the big trade up definitely not a new
england type of thing and i
look i i still think they're in win
now mode the idea of making some big
move to the top of the draft to get a
quarterback who's going to be a great
cam newton for at least a year doesn't
fit with everything we've
seen from the patriots agreed this
season and i
know some folks in boston particularly
on radio there get all up in arms when
we say the patriots love cam newton
but you've heard it i've heard it they
love cam newton
and i know the patriots fans don't love
cam newton because
they see last year yep and they don't
see a path to him being better this year
despite all the players they've added
they had john w smith and hunter henry
and kendrick horn and nelson aguilar
and cam newton's got another year in the
system and he won't have covet this year
and they they just think that it's going
to be a repeat of what they saw in 2020
and it's not
right so that's that yeah if they're
gonna move up
and i don't think they will but if
they're going to move up
i think they're moving up for somebody
they're going to plug in and they're
going to line up right away
not somebody that's going to play in
2022. i i'm 100
with you you know a hundred percent and
to me that goes back to
you know maybe that's why they would
have traded up for a mac jones because
he fits that mold of what you're talking
about a guy that
yeah we could he could play this year
for us we feel like he's nfl ready i
mean you hear everybody say that right i
mean there's not really been anybody
quoted about the quarterbacks that
doesn't say
mac jones is the most nfl ready at this
moment this second so
uh yeah it'll be interesting it's gonna
be very interesting the top ten
i really am gonna be intrigued by it
because as we've discussed a few times
there's lack of top end premium talent
in this draft
so there are going to be a few teams
that are going to go man we like these
players and we have a real need
for this position and this type of
player to want to get up there
to get one of these few elite guys that
are there to
to be had tonight uh for the 2021 draft
and what is amazing about it is
everybody knows
the first two picks everybody knows
there's no way the jaguars aren't taking
trevor lawrence there's no way the jets
aren't taken right jack wilson
you can't function as an organization in
the new york media or with the new york
fans
if you have done nothing to push back
against the presumption that it's zach
wilson
surprises don't go over well with
firemen ed that's not gonna happen it's
lawrence wilson but then
after the first two we don't know what
the hell's gonna happen i can't remember
a draft like that where
first two carve it in stone next date
who the hell knows i know you're right
uh who the hell knows
i mean yeah the 49ers the falcons right
now we're still not sure what the hell
is going on with them
the bangles you hear that like you're
right there's very
few teams we feel like we can really pin
a guy too
that you kind of could you know in years
past just to go oh i mean i think that's
who they're gonna take that makes sense
like
you know i think you know yeah there's a
handful of those guys every year where
you just go
uh i i think that guy's gonna be there
and that's gonna make sense
and all that but there's there's very
little of that this year that's really
what it makes peter king makes it
fascinating
peter king dusted off the notion that
the 49ers will look into trading jimmy
garoppolo on monday and he attached that
second round draft pick to it
as compensation jason lochen for
thereafter reported and i want to get
this right yeah
a very strong expectation among other
general managers that the 49ers are
going to try to trade jimmy garoppolo
that that
let's take that for what it is yes
others in the league
thinking that the phone's going to ring
and that jimmy garoppolo is going to be
available and whether he is or is it
remains to be seen
there is one factor though chris that
may be a bit
diminished the idea that there would be
a schism
in the locker room because george kittle
recently said
the team trusts in kyle shanahan and
john lynch because they haven't led us
astray
yet that is the closest thing we've seen
to
whatever you guys do we're on board
you're going to draft another
quarterback and you're going to put him
on the field and jimmy garoppolo is
either not going to be on the team
or he's going to be on the bench we're
fine with that you know
george kittle will tear up the t-shirt
with jimmy g's picture on it and
and reel in all the things he said about
jimmy garoppolo and he's our guy
no whoever you say our guy is kyle
that's who our guy is and that's what i
think
i think the 49ers organization at the
top needed to hear
in the event that they do hang on to
jimmy garoppolo
in the hopes of getting more for him
later i still think he has to be gone by
week one right but they may get more in
trade
for him later than they would get now
yeah i mean i i
there's definitely that possibility it
is good to hear george kittle like
that's gonna make
you know the the 49ers front office feel
good right
you know that there won't be mutiny or
anything like that it tells you again
yeah the the faith the team has in
shanahan
you know they they they understand that
the guy that's leading their team
is a pretty special offensive mind and
thinker and those type of things so they
believe
you see that but yeah i think ultimately
right i don't think there's going to be
like a war in the locker room
but you're still gonna have guys in that
locker room even though who are gonna go
like hey we trust kyle
they're gonna still look at the corner
of their eye and be like man jimmy was
good like jimmy's the man why don't we
let him be the quarterback and
maybe not fully emotionally give
themselves to the other quarterback
because there's still like an emotional
attachment to the old guy there
that's what i would worry about and
that's where it can like
yeah maybe not really allow a team to
come together and be a hundred percent
cohesive that way
and that's why i ultimately think yes he
gets traded i'm not so sure it happens
this weekend
but i think it happens for sure sometime
between now
and i'm gonna say the end of otas i
would think like
that i would think he's gone before
training camp that would be mine i agree
yeah here's another reason here's
another reason
they they want to move on from him
because he gets hurt all the time
okay they've admitted that yeah they've
admitted that right now now also
also you know he freaked out kyle in the
division round of the playoffs in 2019
and he became bob griese for the rest of
the postseason until the super bowl
during which he played well until the
fourth quarter when he fell apart
and missed emanuel sanders with a
championship throw other than that he's
been fine
my point is this if you're concerned
about his ability to stay healthy
and you put him in a pre-season game
that's right and he
suffers a serious injury that's right
stuck yeah with a 24.1 million
salary i remember back in 2008 when the
ravens wanted steve mcnair
the titans had was it 2008 or 2006.
whatever
it was 2006 it was here they drafted
vince young
they wanted steve mcnair out and they
locked him out of the building
they wouldn't let steve mcnair in
because if if he dropped a
dumbbell on his foot and he was out for
the year they had a 10 million dollar
cap charge which was a huge deal in
2006. so
you don't want a guy that you're
concerned about getting injured
in a spot where he could get injured and
you know under that circumstance
you don't want him in the building at
all if if you think this guy is
fragile you don't want him working out
in your weight room you don't want him
running on your practice field you don't
want him doing anything because one
false step and the 49ers saw this pre
kyle and john lynch they saw with
michael crabtree
when he popped an achilles during an ota
right you're stuck for 24.1 million
dollars this year
yeah no no doubt about it i think all
those those factors are very real and
mike i mean we got one on our text right
now just
like uh i i see schefter put out a tweet
explaining this one minute ago uh you
want me to read it
well go ahead you read it now
interpreter okay multiple teams are
expected to contact the 49ers today to
inquire about the availability of
quarterback jimmy garoppolo per sources
but
as of early this morning the chances of
him being traded are
in the words of one source remote
let's see if anything changes in the
next 72 hours
all right i'll interpret it the source
is don yee jimmy garoppolo's agent
because there's a strong connection
between you and schefter
and this is the message that don't get
your hopes up that jimmy g's taking a
big pay cut
that's why it's remote because he's
making 25 million this year
right so he's got no reason to cut it to
10 million now
he can wait till later now here's the
problem you wait too
long and the 49ers cut you see i think
donye realizes they're not going to do
that we're going to come to you right
before the start of the regular season
and say you got to slash your salary in
half or more than in half
or we're going to cut you for the the
reason we're very fortuitous the reason
we're just discussing
they don't want to risk owning them 24.1
million it's not going to last that long
at the latest
if they are going to cut him they're
going to take the best offer they can
get
or they're going to cut him right before
training camp and if you cut him right
before training camp
he's got time to go somewhere else
especially if
don yee sees which way the wind's
blowing and has made some calls of some
teams saying trust me
my guy is going to be available just as
you're reporting for camp i think that's
that it's that 24 million dollar
question
i think that's what keeps the 49ers from
from holding him until labor day weekend
and
saying you're taking 10 million this
year you're taking a hike and good luck
finding another job
right they don't want the risk he gets
injured during the pre-season or in
training
that's real that is real the thing is
you know
with jimmy g you know he could take the
risk of losing out on a chance to be a
starter still though
if he does wait too long himself right
to maybe make some of these concessions
or do that
you know whether that's if the bears
would be interested
you know you know if new england i think
if you got too far down the road with
them
all right they're just going to go wait
it's the middle of august cam's
practicing good we like it sorry we're
not going to mess with our team right
now
you know i would worry about those type
of things to now it's like
wait it's gone a little too long and now
you might get cut
and not make anything close to 24
million so
that's where they're gonna have to
balance it out and then this is another
thing that kind of popped in my mind as
we were talking about this with the
49ers hey the 49ers may they might not
be in a rush to trade them this weekend
you know the the other thing too is they
might want to just keep them through
otas and things like that just to
to make sure their rookie quarterback is
everything they thought he was gonna be
you know for the proverbial hope he
doesn't crap the bed now that he gets
here in the nfl
and once you get to see that and go okay
he's good he's comfortable all that
all right now we can get rid of jimmy g
there's that factor too
to where maybe they hang on to them just
for a little bit just so they can
get their guy in the building and know
that hey he's ready to to take the reins
one last point that reinforces my belief
that this is don
yee putting the word out as matt casey
notes key word first word
multiple multiple teams are expected to
contact the 49ers in other words there's
going to be a market
for my guy yeah multiple teams many
teams
are saying they want jimmy garoppolo we
were trying to figure out last night who
would want him texans
bears and another one that slips my mind
patriots duh i mean we're already
talking about the patriots but the
patriots texas bears that's it
that's really it right i mean denver's
off the table so i mean
it comes down to those to those teams i
don't know who else could be
realistically out there to be thinking
that
so i guess those are the multiple teams
we're we're talking about here
all it takes is two two is multiple two
and even then
even then it's not easy to find two
clear and obvious destinations for jimmy
g but if there were only two i would say
texans and patriots because you've got
the history there
you've got the knowledge of jimmy
garoppolo and uh
you know arguably you have the need i
still i still think about the jermaine
wiggins quote from six seven weeks ago
yeah right former patriot who's now on
weei saying that there are patriots
players that kind of looked at jimmy g
sideways can we count on you
he had a four game audition in 2016. he
got injured in game two
yeah it's and if i'm bill belichick what
well i don't know do you go with do you
go with cam newton and jimmy g do you
come up with a two quarterback offense
and you use them both i don't know i
don't know but uh
i this gets back to what we're saying we
keep hearing that they like cam newton
why would they want jimmy g but uh maybe
they want the familiarity maybe they
want the flexibility yeah
we'll see hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports